welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
so recently i did a video about how
amazon is buying mgm
and with that they're buying the rights
to stargate and how that is leading to
many rumors that stargate might actually
make a return
in this video i'm going to talk about if
one of our favorite tv shows really does
make a return
what might it actually look like so if
you're on new channel please like
subscribe hit that bell notification
really helps us out so first of all
there's the
sequel kind of series just carrying on
from where sgu left off maybe not within
the sg universe we might not find out
what happened to the destiny guys
but
on earth
14 years or so after sg-1 finished
amanda tapping and michael shanks have
apparently already been approached and
asked about maybe doing some directing
and maybe appearing in front of the
screen too and both have openly talked
about it brad wright has also openly
talked about his plans for this show
so at the moment that seems like the
most likely scenario that this new tv
show will be not a reboot but a sequel
14 years after sg-1 ended
we might find out where the towery fleet
is now
we saw over the 10 years of sg-1 that we
were able to build a small but very
capable fleet of battle cruisers
where are we now
we know that stargate atlantis ended
with basically the atlantic city landing
in san francisco bay
so
we can assume maybe then that everybody
on the planet knows about the stargate
program now it's no longer a secret
and in that case
how has that changed the world
we also know that we basically have
access to several elements of asgard
technology even though the holy grail
the database of the asda technology was
lost we still had access to several asda
technologies including shields weapons
etc we don't know how much that will
have pushed us on and obviously like i
just mentioned stargate atlantis is sat
in the middle of san francisco bay so
you know we have a whole city of ancient
technology to explore and to really you
know
where it was quite a small team in
stargate atlantis exploring this city
and now they would have
the entire resource of the planet to
find out what's going on on this um this
this floating city i'm fascinated to see
how the relationship between the jaffa
nation and the taori has has continued
to grow because it's not been exactly
smooth
i'd also love to see i i genuinely
believe there will probably be civil
wars within the jaffa nation that's
something we could explore and you've
also got the lucian alliance and their
rise to power as the um you know they
they took up the vacuum of power if the
gold collapsed all of these would make
really interesting side story lines and
plots that twist through the series but
you really need a
new protagonist a new bad guy and if
stargate sg1 taught us anything they
that they're pretty good at that
the gold wall started to come a little
bit old we brought in the system lords
and that can have been old we saw the
rise of anubis we saw the rise of the
replicators we obviously saw the ori um
and so
this was a show that kept reinventing
itself and brad wright was really good
at that so i don't see any reason why
using the breadth of human history which
is what you've done throughout stargate
i mean a lot of these
um
bad guys and nemesis aren't really you
know brought up of nowhere and maybe the
ori and and the replicators were but um
you know they all actually had seeds
from human history and there's a lot of
history they haven't touched yet so you
know they focus on the egyptians in
egyptian history we have seen some roman
and things like that but there's a lot
of more they could explore and they're
not new bad guys they they could
certainly come up with
the rise to power of the lucy alliance
was never really explained
perhaps there is some dark figure behind
that some leader that we haven't
actually seen yet
perhaps that could be the new
protagonist
so i see that as the most likely
scenario for a new series but there are
obviously other ideas and i've had loads
of comments and some of them were just
fantastic one in particular was sort of
like the prequel series now i
immediately go
i don't like prequels
um i think they mess with canon
um star trek enterprise is the prime
example for me it's so dangerous and
you're so restrictive for what you can
do with the series because you've got so
much cannon that follows after it you
can't mess about with
so it's it limits what you can do and
what ends up happening is that you do
something with a series that is exciting
and interesting and it changes canon
like
uh the zindy attack on earth never ever
been mentioned in star trek before but
there's a massive gouge right through
the middle of the you know of america's
uh
southwest whatever that actually
appeared in the first jj abrams star
trek um you know that's what uh young
james t kirk shoots his the car off into
it's the it's the zindy attack but you
know i've never mentioned staff before
enterprise thought of it they wrote it
into the story it you know
was the catalyst for how the federation
came together in lots of ways and but it
would never be mentioned in canon so you
know there's lots of there's lots of
dangers doing a prequel but
this idea
would be so far before sg-1 that it
doesn't really risk
messing with canon because the idea is
to base a series on the ancients and the
ancients building the stargate network
in the first place
i actually find that really fascinating
i want to see sort of why did they build
the stargate
maybe why did they launch the destiny
and we could even see maybe that we
could see we could maybe even see a
series that sort of jumps between
ancient history and maybe doesn't follow
like one clear storyline maybe that it
sort of jumps through thousands of years
potentially
how did the ancients get so powerful how
did the ancients end up ascending you
know these are all stories that could be
really really interesting and then they
could always tie into sg-1 stargate
atlantis
episodes because you know how many times
do we see something the atlanteans did
or the atlanteans set up or you know the
ancients weapons or whatever
you know how many times did we see that
and it could tie into so many sg1
episodes so i think that could be a
fascinating
prequel series that wouldn't risk
messing with canon and it could actually
use canon and that would be very very
interesting to me the third possibility
that i can see
is a future series
so set the new sg series 100 years into
the future now there are so many other
things with that this could be really
really interesting obviously all the
stuff i talked about how um
how we know with the jaffa nation where
is the jaffa nation
where is the lucian lines all of that
stuff that i talked about with just a
sort of a modern sequel sort of series
like the next generation type series we
could take that whole thing to a whole
other level
has earth and humans
become the third race that the asgard
always talked about
we could go out into the universe and
start
bringing all of these human colonies
that spread amongst the galaxies back
together again
we could
create an alliance a federation
of people that spread across entire
galaxy but in both that
this future hundred years in the future
series or like i said the next
generation sort of style sequel series
both have to address the gold world now
the gold world are one of the most
important bad guys in star game they
they're really epitome of stargate um
where are they now because you know
these people aren't going to have just
disappeared into the nothingness
they're going to have some sort of
future
they're they're sneaky they're selfish
and they're intelligent
you know we saw that with like ball and
things these aren't stupid creatures
they're not going to have just
disappeared into the nothingness forever
there is going to be a comeback and when
they come back i'd love to see how they
do that also with either of these two
series either 100 years into the future
or sort of the next generation sort of
roughly our timeline series
you've also got the problem that
like i said humanity would know about
this now but more importantly the rest
of the universe knows about humanity we
have stepped in enough dog poop around
the universe that everybody knows we're
here and they are going to come and
threaten us and attack us
how would we cope with that are we going
to see earth defenses an earth fleet
like i've said all these lovely things
that we like in star trek we're going to
get to hopefully see
um in stargate the technology the ships
all this stuff that we really really
love to as geeks to get our teeth into
but there is a big risk stargate
obviously isn't star trek it is
different
and this series i'm talking about here
would fundamentally change what stargate
is
i'm not 100 certain i want to see that
but with that scenario with us building
new ships a new fleet stepping out into
the universe you've then got the danger
of us putting heads with the lucian
alliance with the jaffa nation and like
i said earlier these are all interesting
storylines and how our relationship
would build with those powers but i
don't think it would make an interesting
long-term series we need
a threat
like an anubis like and a replicators
that comes in two or three episodes a
series and is a real danger to the
entire galaxy sort of thing
out of all of the comments i got though
this is by far the best one
we want to see walter is the commander
and i love that idea um because it's
like we talked about maybe amanda
tapping with the commander maybe michael
shanks with the commander but how about
walter
what a fantastic idea
but
would it be funnier
to have walter
back
but actually doing exactly the same job
still saying
chevron one encoded chevron two encoded
still sat there doing it
would that be funny
i'm gonna go for the latter i want to
see him just sat there punching buttons
in still but um that would be amazing so
what do i think is the most likely
scenario here i think the next
generation style of um
new series is the most likely it'll be
set in roughly the same timeline as now
it will be a whole new team
i think they will try to bring back
teal
for at least a few episodes um i think
um amanda tapping is a very successful
very in-demand tv director now and i
think they would love to get her back
onto the series um behind the camera and
at least in part in front of it
and i know
uh daniel jackson michael shanks loves
this series and would come back in a
heartbeat
and he is he has said so on multiple
occasions in in interviews um based on
earth using the stargates but also the
new ships being built
a new relationship with the jaffa and
the dilution lines new threats
and potentially i'm a whole new younger
team brad right keeps talking about a
younger team some that's going to sort
of like make sense to a younger audience
and that is another thing as well
there's a lot of the comments i had
about a reboot or a new series of
stargate
said over and over again for the love of
god don't make it woke now that's not a
term i like
i don't like this term but um it's it's
said an awful lot by by my subscribers
and people who watch the video and that
basically means it's it's try not to
make the series too much like we don't
have to have every single
gender transgender
every single culture and race um within
the team we don't have to have everybody
represented it doesn't have to
um be this this this type of series
um but i would say
sci-fi or good sci-fi reflects culture
they tell stories that have a moral
without you necessarily knowing that
you're being taught immoral if that
makes sense
that's when sci-fi is at its best it's
not just laser beams and weapons it's
you come away going there's layers to
the story
stargate did that star trek was the best
doing that
um even star wars to a degree
you know the best sci-fi always does
that and i want to see a new star gate
series do exactly the same
so
all right i don't want it forced on it i
want it to be part of the series i want
it to be
you know i want it to be relevant to the
story
but i have absolutely no problem with
all elements of our modern culture being
represented in this new tv series so
that makes it a bit woke
so be it as long as it makes sense to
the story how likely do i think this is
i actually think this is incredibly
likely i know this original story come
from giant freaking robot and they are
basically a bunch of clickbaiters
but
the story does make sense amazon
like disney plus like netflix is
screaming out for new content
after the james bond franchise mgm's
most successful and most profitable
um entity
thing they own
is stargate
so
as soon as amazon get their hands on
this channel and it's not not fully
even though amazon and mgm are starting
to work together already there's an mdm
channel on amazon it's the only place
you can get stargate now i have to pay
for it because i'm watching all of sgu
again
even though they're already working
together amazon does not yet quite own
mgm
i think as soon as they do
and mgm start getting a hold of a bit of
amazon money we will see new projects
but more importantly we will get them
looking back at their back catalog we
will get mgm looking at right what do we
own
and now we're not crippled by debt
what can we make
and i think stargate will be very very
high up on that list
if you would love to buy this t-shirt
that is modeled by myself you can
tell me in the comments where you think
this uh little quote came from if you're
british you're probably gonna have a
good idea if you're american you might
have to google it
and there is a link in the description
where you can purchase one all for
yourself
[Music]
you